Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number. That number
is two one nine two. David P. Here's a conspiracy
theory that the Alec Baldwin shooting was a
false flag meant to Costco to confiscate guns.
Speaker 7: Hey, David, it's
true, Amanda. Anti-intellectual.
It's sad what happened with Alec Baldwin?
The part that isn't being shared is that.
The gun was planted with the real
Speaker 1: bullet
planted to the very conspiratorial language.
Speaker 7: The left has an excuse and a reason
to say, see, we need to take remains
on the guns. We need to regulate.
We need to disarm the population of these guns.
Why don't you mention that in your discussion,
Speaker 1: because there is absolutely no evidence
to suggest that this is the exact same argument
that some made about the Sandy Hook school
shooting when Barack Obama was president? It was
staged in order to have a big national tragedy to
then subsequently try to confiscate guns. What's
pathetic is, even after the Sandy Hook shooting,
we couldn't even get universal background checks
passed, never mind confiscating any guns. And the
reason I haven't mentioned at Trotman is that
there is no reason whatsoever to believe that
that's what took place. We've got a great bonus
show for you today. Don't let this stuff rot your
brain. Sign up at Join Pack Mint.com. We will see
Unidentified: you on the boat.